speaking of politicians
speaking of
speaking of the center and the right
kind of moving moving so far to the left
now that the the hard strong right wing
position is that men are not women and
women are not men Arkansas state senator
Matt McKee is under Fire right now for
grilling a transgender Witness
there's a dude dressed up as a chick
and he asked this man a question that
you are no longer allowed to ask the
transgender people
recognized
are you telling us that you're
unfamiliar with a large body of medical
evidence of the harm that has come upon
people that have gone through these
processes I'm familiar with a large body
of evidence that shows that providing
good affirming care saves lives are you
saying that you're unaware of the large
body of medical evidence of the harm
that has come upon these people in these
processes have been gone through how are
you unaware of that body of evidence I
will repeat what I just said are you
unaware of that repeat what I just said
you said that you're a trans woman I
trans female yes sir do you have a penis
that's horrible you're the one you're
the one that brought that into the
discussion you're the one that never
said anything about genitalia oh yeah
everything that's horrible how dare you
ask the
why is that so bad
I I remember this was a big deal when
some confused man went on a talk show I
think it was Laverne Cox whatever his
real name is from Orange is the New
Black and he went on one of the network
talk shows and the interviewer said do
you have
do you still have your do you still have
the goods and this was so shocking how
dare you can't ask this person that
question
why not
the Crux of a lot of opposition to
transgenderism don't forget 80
opposition in America to transgenderism
specifically as it applies to kids
hinges on the idea that dudes can go
into the girl's locker room and get
naked so whether or not a person has
their genitals is a pivotal question
here
how dare you ask that question good on
this guy Matt McKee I hope that a lot of
conservatives take this lesson and and
not only don't run away from the the
left wing oh my goodness clutching my
pearls I hope they actively seek it out
I hope that in every one of these
testimonies
about the transgender issue I hope that
the conservatives ask this question
seek it out the this is a winning issue
for us
and the the more that the radical
pro-trans people in the room start
screaming like Banshees
the the more the normal sane people are
going to be convinced that they are
right about this issue keep it up good
job state senator Matt McKee I really
wanted to get to the crane and Company
will Thomas Leah Thomas story today they
had an explosive interview about that
that swimmer the big giant dude who
swims on the girls team and takes the
trophies away from all the girls at
UPenn but we don't have time to do that
we've got to get to a more important
story I think so we'll get to that
tomorrow if you haven't watched the
granny Co interview on this though make
sure you go check out that interview
today the Georgia state senator Emmanuel
Jones just highlighted the
the deep unseriousness but but political
Danger of of this new kind of liberal
activism in a way that's kind of banal
and we've all heard it before but but
his explanation tells you a lot about it
this guy state senator Jones called
Clarence Thomas you're going to be
shocked to hear it and Uncle Tom
place the statue of Clarence Thomas on
this grounds we cannot avoid that
conversation so I'm not going to avoid
it either
in the black community we have an
expression
and I don't want to use this label too
deeply hear because I'm just trying to
tell you what we have in
African-American Community when we talk
about a person of color
that goes back historically the days of
slavery and that person betraying his
own Community we have a term in the
black community
that term that we use is called Uncle
Tom
and Uncle Tom is a either fictional or
non-fictional character I don't really
know the origin of Uncle Tom but it
talks about a person who back during the
days of slavery sold his soul to the
slave masters
this Clarence Thomas he's an Uncle Tom
and what's an Uncle Tom it's either a
fictional or a non-fictional you know
come to think of it I have no idea who
the hell Uncle Tom is but I'm going to
call Clarence Thomas one because I don't
like him
that sums it up perfectly
that sums it all up
hey I don't have any idea what I'm
talking about but screw you Clarence
Thomas that's those are the attacks
generally on Clarence Thomas and on most
conservatives
but it shows you something that I have
been yelling about for years and wrote a
whole book about that became a number
one National bestseller speechless
controlling words controlling minds and
that we've got to pay a lot of attention
to
idioms
crop up
that people often use unthinkingly
this guy is using the idiom Uncle Tom
unthinkingly he doesn't know what it
means
but that that happens for a lot of us
all the time
let there be light forbidden fruit am I
My Brother's Keeper fire and brimstone
the blind leading the blind go the extra
mile
all of those idioms come from the Bible
most people don't know that they come
from the Bible
in in fact many people who have never
read the Bible
who don't believe in the Bible will use
those idioms all the time that's that's
how culture works it it culture works by
certain texts by certain pieces of art
by certain rituals just creeping in and
not only becoming and not only being
inserted into your language but actually
coming to constitute your language and
by constituting your language it
constitutes the way that you think and
that's what you're seeing here
with Uncle Tom
this guy has no idea what the the
context of Uncle Tom is he just knows
that Uncle Tom means black people aren't
supposed to be conservative that's what
he knows about Uncle Tom and so he just
says it beep boop he's not thinking this
is not a particularly conscious human
being but he's just saying
Clarence Thomas he's Republican he's
conservative bad Uncle Tom it's wrong
you got to vote Democrat beep beep beep
boop and that's how culture works and
the libs have done a very very good job
and as they are pushing the Bible out of
our culture as they're pushing the Bible
out of schools they're pushing these
idioms they're pushing these ways of
thinking they're pushing this language
out of our head that's why they're so
obsessed about doing that that's why
they're so obsessed about putting the
weird gay porn and the weird liberal
intersectionist texts into the schools
the reason they're doing that is not so
you can learn some lesson
about a racial hierarchy I mean that's a
that's a secondary effect that they like
but it's more so that your brain just
becomes shaped and filled with these
this kind of language these kinds of
images and so you will unthinkingly
carry out their plans you won't even
know that you're doing it go to
dailywire.com Knowles use code Knowles
at checkout for two months free on all
annual plans
[Music]
foreign